hello everyone and welcome to the game
you guys have been requesting me to show
and of course as usual for good reasons
it is Spain versus India the India's
second team and on board one we have
Alexis Shiro versus gukish you you guys
all know of course Alexa sure of um the
master of the Mystic Arts he always
plays the the sharpest chest possible
and he is gooker's first opponent that
is rated over 2700 in this Olympiad uh
so you know it is going to be a good
game and as I've seen it I know that
it's a good game so let's dive straight
into it and see uh can uh can India
continue on this path of uh you know
continuous Victory or will Spain have
something to say about it so uh shirov
with the white pieces opens with E4 and
we get the best reply possible that of
course is Pawn to C5 as Alexa is known
to be one of the greatest attackers that
ever played chess so of course seeing
the Sicilian Defense uh is incredibly
enjoyable people with Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and now not what you might
expect an open Sicilian but rather
Knight the C3 uh going for uh this close
setup against the Sicilian we have E5 uh
Bishop to C4 uh developing the bishop
nicely D6 D3 and pawn to H6 we have
Knight to D5 and grabbing that Central
Outpost for the Knight and Knight to F6
by gookish C3 and now Bishop to E7 we
have A3 and now there is a game uh where
Castle was played but of course gookish
not about to allow uh shirov to just
play B4 whenever he wants to so he plays
A5 and it is now as of move 80 that we
have a completely new game and it is
exactly at this moment when we have a
completely new game uh that shirov again
surprises us with his Mastery and he
plays a rook to G1 such a such a fine
move uh you know he's not hiding
anything everyone knows he wants to
attack he wants to play G for G5 and the
point is okay if Lucas may be castles
here then just Knight captures Bishop
captures G4 and the black is already in
trouble G5 is coming the the really
isn't a good way to deal with this so
after Rook to G1 gokish says all right
I'm not I'm not even gonna castle
kingside since we already announced that
you are starting an attack I'm gonna
play Knight captures on D5 Bishop
captures on D5 in the now Bishop to E6
uh Bishop captures an E6 with f captures
and E6 and now uh Shiro continues with
his plan of pushing the pawn to G4 we
have Queen to D7 and now Pawn to G5 we
have a trade H capture the bishop
captures Bishop captures Rook captures
and now bookish just says I'm out of
here and castles Queen side we have
Queen the E2 shirov also prepares the
castle Queen side Rook D to f8 in the
now shoot of castles Queen side and now
Rook to F7 so if you look at the
position now the material is completely
equal however there is the problem of
the G7 Pawn but it's not really an issue
it's nicely defended uh Shiro on the
other hand has the F2 pawn and the H2
pawns to worry about and of course they
can be defended but it might be a bit
trickier than defending the 1g7 pawn so
here Rook back the G2 and uh Pawn to A4
now just creating a beautiful Outpost
for his Knight and B3 and this is
something that Shiro will have to worry
about for the rest of the game Rook data
G1 and now Pawn to B5 we have Knights
the G5 attacking The Rook putting
pressure on the E6 spawn maybe preparing
Queen G4 so just Rook the E7 uh keeping
an eye on everything and now uh shoot up
is out of active moves and he should
just wait and see what Lucas will do
with some prophylactic King B1 or maybe
a knight back to F3 uh just uh you know
keeping the the position as it is but
shirov is not the kind of player that
just Waits and see what happens he has
to be the one controlling it and he uh
goes for a central breakthrough with
Pawn to D4 now opening up a discovery on
that B5 pawn and the position is now
uh much much different than it was
before this D4 move as everything is
hanging so he captures on D4 and now
Queen captures and B5 he opens up the
queen sign Knight the E5 offering a
queen trade and if you go for the queen
trade right away uh then we're gonna
play King captures on D7 and black is
just much better here for example C
captures and the 4C captures Rook D1
going after the pawn Knight to C6 and
this is uh very very nicely uh played by
uh well I have a hypothetical line that
would have been nicely played now some
E5 defending they spawn the Knight can
still come to B3 and the black is always
better so shirov says um all right let's
try something different Queen to A6
check uh Queen to B7 in the now Queen
captures and B7 this is how shirov
decides to trade queens and now the King
has to go away from the center as The
Rook has to stay here to defend this
Pawn so King captures in the now C
captures on D4 C captures and Rook to D1
similar like in the line that we've
discussed but after Knight the C6 and F4
you have the black king and B7 instead
of on D7 and this is now
uh well the position is still favorable
for gookish but it is uh easier to play
this with white uh you can't just start
activating the root The Rook is now
stuck guarding that E6 Pawn Yeah so here
we have Pawn the E5 getting rid of the
weakness and here shirov plays F5 and
believe it or not this F5 move uh is uh
what starts shirov's downfall here you
have to play e captures uh f-captors and
E5 but it's uh not clear uh why before
you you check out the game but one of
the reasons is that you will force a
capture here and then this Pawn will not
be controlling the C5 Square which will
be very very important later on so here
Ponte F5 and now comes Knight the A5 by
gukash of course you you could have
expected this move Knight to E6 as you
now have the control over D for square
Knight B3 check we have King to B1 and
the now King the B6 and here uh the
problem is you can never capture this G7
having fun if you play Knight captures
and G7 then Rook to G8 and now okay you
can't move the knight uh otherwise
you're gonna lose the Rook so Rook D to
G1 and now Rook the C7 and there is no
good way to survive this if you play F6
we're just gonna play D3 there there's
no playing this if Knight the E6 going
for uh some sort of an attack here then
we can even just play Rook captures on
G2 Rook captures and now deliver
Checkmate Roxy one check King A2 and
Rook day one Checkmate so you can't move
the Rooks you can't really trade the
trade any material you're gonna get to
checkmated and if you just do nothing
then this Pawn comes all the way to D2
and then of course it resigns so here
Rook the C2 should have now says all
right you can have the king side I'm
going after the queen side this is my
only chance I have to make some breeding
room for my king here uh Rook to H4
going after the E4 pawn and now Rook the
C4 we have captures an E4 captures an A4
and now comes Knight to C5 attacking The
Rook here Rook the B for check and King
to C6 and now you can see how this Pawn
being here is doing so much for black
just um you know the king is incredibly
safe here and it's much much different
than if those pawns got traded off
instead of pushing F5 so Rook the C1 and
now comes Rook to E2 gukash now
puts pressure on the second Rank and
also is ready to start pushing that D
pawn and uh how can you do this uh for
example uh H4 was played in the game as
the H2 Pawn is attacked but also if you
try Rook the B8 which seems like such a
fine idea preparing B4 to win the knight
uh still just D3 and the gookish wins
yeah if Now Pawn to B4 just D2 and you
you don't really have a good reply to
this you have to now give up The Rook uh
characters with Queen uh King captures
the d-captors and C5 and you have two
Rooks Against The Rook in the Knight of
course gookish would be completely
winning here so H4 saving the H Pawn and
now we have King to D5 we Rook the B5
now again hoping to get that b for
moving but just King the E4 Knight
captures and C5 the characters and now
Rook C captures and C5 looks very nice
shirov is even up a pawn but it doesn't
matter Pawn to D3 we have think the C1
now comes King to F3 Rook to C3 now
pinning the d-pawn but now Pawn to E4 we
have rooked to D5 uh King to E3 we have
Pawn to B4 finally yeah it starts
marching forward but now just the rookie
one check King the B2 and here we have
King to E2 and it was in this position
on move 44 that Alex isiro resigned to
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here Hereafter a few moves uh well
there's basically no good defense
against D2 D1 if you if you try to
double up Rooks on the default just E3
uh you can play this of course then Rook
to E6 is incredibly strong uh but what
you can play is E3 and now Rook C to D6
okay it seems like you're doing
something but not really D2 and if B5
just D1 Queen and that's it uh captures
captures characters captures captures
Europe of a full Rook of course this is
completely winning so another incredible
win by gookish with the black pieces
against the uh against the legend like
Alexis shirov so yeah big
congratulations on that and also here is
a very nice photo of Team India too now
if you guys are interested here we have
it pragananda Adib
so incredible team incredible photo and
incredible games are being played so I
hope you hope you enjoyed this one uh
you can see uh uh just just a beautiful
beautiful photo and also since you guys
requested me to show this uh oops that's
not the one uh this is the one uh yeah
okay it might be a bit tiny for those of
you watching on your smartphone but it's
basically the world's top 39 players uh
basically the only 39 players in the
world as of today who are rated over
2700 on the live ratings list you can
see that wukish is number 27 in the
world after winning this game he even
overtook with it the visit is 28 gukash
is 27 uh is currently on 27 14.1
and well if he continues this then he
could even jump into the the world top
20 but we'll see it's still a long way
to go and you can see Carlson all the
way up there chilling with his
2864.7 uh as uh well uh he he got three
wins in the draw and he is currently on
plus 0.7 so you know he's getting closer
to that 2900 rating but it's taking him
a while uh so that's the game and the
nice photo and the live ratings hope you
guys enjoyed that we're gonna cover one
more game from this round and then we're
gonna discuss the uh the standings who
is leading uh tomorrow I believe uh
India 2 is facing Armenia but I'm not
sure I will have to check as not all of
the games have finished while I'm making
this video uh so I will inform you in
the next one as well that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it maybe we see a
clash of the unbeatables maybe gookish
versus abdusator of that would be that
would definitely be a
incredible matchup to watch but you know
if they continue playing like this it's
bound to happen I would like to thank
David Kimura Esmond Alden Jacob Tobias
Derek King and Felix dafo for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Olympiad until it finishes so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day